man
man okay y'all it's my birthday today it
is my birthday i am officially 38 years
old
i'm an old man so we're picking back up
with thor and uh
son okay man okay the last issue was
legit right the last issue was amazing
this one's even better okay so here's
the thing so thor ever the man's man
after getting his arm destroyed by the
god of hammers which is basically merged
with with like man gog right just the
sentience of rage right just rage
unbridled just wildly powerful this
indestructible being that cannot be
killed uh essentially thor just like
sets his arm right and he's like okay
like let's let's see what's going on
thor has this statement that he makes
and he's like so that's it right like
you've been possessed by the man gog
well you've come to the right place
mjolnir
i can help you let me beat that demon
out of you right i absolutely love i i
love that moment right like i love that
so at that point it's one of those
things where the hammer kind of makes
this argument and saying like not
possessed right join intertwined now
here's the thing to understand this is
the important thing to understand one
does not simply join with man gog right
it doesn't work that way man gog is
literally just rage and cardiff those
guys who don't know who man gog is man
gog is just this horrifying thing right
it's like the only thing that odin is
afraid of and odin's fought galactus
rightly you thought galactus to a stanza
well technically head by the galactus
and then like fractured as hell but like
you guys get the point right i mean he's
fought some super powerful people the
idea behind mangog is that somewhere
along the line there was a race that
odin had led to the destruction of he
had basically conquered and destroyed
them and in doing so they channeled all
their rage and anger into a singular
entity which became the man god whenever
this guy shows up all hell breaks loose
like as guardians will just die there's
no way to truly kill this guy and so a
fight ultimately starts to break out
between the two now in this moment right
in this fight you actually have this
moment because of the fact that odin is
largely incapacitated what you get is
basically beta ray bill stepping up
right now here's the thing this we kind
of skipped over this little second
because it's actually how it opens but
technically what happens is like beta
ray bill basically grabs all these
different superheroes on earth and from
across the realms and it's like if you
wish to leave now is the time he's like
in this battle that we're going to face
one way or another it's going to end in
blood some of us will not survive this
just so you know so if you are soft
if you are weak at the knees if you are
incapable of handling the kind of threat
that we're going to be facing off
against here then head on home watch
your favorite shows eat some more meals
and nobody's really well everybody's
going to think less of you but like you
know milk stops go do your thing
[Laughter]
goby milk stops and in the end none of
them really seem to go away now one of
the things to know this is not like an
entire like the entire coming together
of the whole superhero community i mean
it's some of them right like it's it's
the ones that material could get a hold
of but you still got some heavy hitters
here right you're talking about doctor
strange you're talking about wolverine
which i don't even know what he's gonna
do but you got like like ben graham
which i don't know what he'll do either
but like most of these guys are here and
it's kind of cool but it's one of those
things where in the end thor tells them
like no right do not come here and when
they initially believe that they can
somehow basically engage in this fight
it doesn't work because what they're
doing is they're fighting what is in
effect one part cosmic entity and one
part just energy source it's not easily
defeated the only one here that could
truly pull off a feat and having a
chance in beating this guy would
basically be like doctor strange or iron
man and with iron man it's only because
of his repulsor beams but even then it's
very limited in scale instead where dr
strange steps in and doctor strange
tries to defeat this thing ultimately it
doesn't work and so what ends up
happening is thor does the only thing he
can do right thor prays and this is
crazy right because he he like literally
reaches out and says mother like i need
you please please hear me grant me your
gifts give me your power so that i may
protect those in need so that i may
serve my father and then boom the power
comes and that's when he literally
unleashes this colossal maelstrom that
no one can get through now here's the
cool thing about this right because i
imagine a lot of you guys are kind of
like okay what's going on here that's
literally what iron man says iron man's
like okay anybody know what the hell is
going on
[Laughter]
because literally this giant tornado
came out of nowhere and that's when reed
is just sort of like okay so like it
appears to be a kind of well for lack of
a better better term energy tornado
right but it's not behaving in any
natural way that has ever been recorded
he's like for one all of us should be
dead standing next to an energy source
this strong and so the the conclusion
that reed richards draws is that it
seems to be something that the hammer's
doing that's when freya chimes in and
says no this was not caused by by the
hammer this was caused by thor and in
the end the response of of reed is like
okay but that doesn't really make any
sense right because like without his
hammer how could thor whip up a
maelstrom like this and that's when she
says no no right he is more than a
hammer he's a child of midgard i raised
him but his birth mother is gaia herself
mjolnir may rebel against thor but the
earth bends its knee now here's a very
very important distinction here because
what's been going on in recent months is
there's been a lot of back and forth in
marvel comics and really to the dismay
of a lot of thor fans to be honest with
you guys i mean for the people who are
like old-school thor fans they don't
want to see the mythos change they're
kind of pissed off for people who are
like new to thor and they don't really
know one way or the other it's probably
just passing curiosity but for years and
years and years when i say years i mean
like decades in marvel comics thor is
the was the biological child of odin and
gaia right like mother earth basically
so at the end of the day what ended up
happening is during jason aaron's run
what he did is he shifted things up and
he said that quote unquote the phoenix
force is the mother of thor the issue
with that is we didn't really know what
form that took like we had no real idea
what was going on so jason aaron's kind
of been doing his own thing but marvel
as a whole largely seems to be sticking
with the idea that thor is the child of
gaia right like that's his biological
mom and that's why he has the the potent
ability to control the elements of the
world and so what's really really cool
is that in the end there's a kind of you
know maybe a bit of a discussion that
happens between the two and initially it
seems a little lackluster but initially
it's just kind of like okay i mean this
could certainly be better but what's
really cool about this is in fact dottie
cates ties this into everything right
thor asked the question why why did you
do this why have you killed so many in
my name i don't understand and the
hammer says i used to bleed across the
stars thor i was beautiful the mother
storm shapeless incandescent lights
broke and scattered across my body i was
alive i was feared luminous and dreadful
and free your father trapped me eons ago
he used me enchanted me treated me like
i was a toy it took so long but the man
gog opened my eyes he's another of your
father's sense and she says you know he
taught me that the gods deserve a
reckoning for the games that they play
and so we began to unravel them all of
odin's little toys we began to tweak
them to set them free and that's when
you learned like the midgard serpent
didn't just randomly appear in the realm
of donald blake during the praise
storyline you guys remember that we
covered that video when donald blake
escaped and went crazy because he had
basically just lost his mind been
trapped inside his own little dimension
that's where he was basically sent to
whenever uh thor took over whenever like
the thor personality came back and quote
unquote donald blake went away thor
never really seemed to fully know what
was going on and the curse was that
donald blake was locked inside this town
but ultimately when the midgard serpent
came in a way in is a way out and so
with the entire little world being
destroyed and donald blake already going
crazy it offered him a way out and
that's what the hammer was shooting for
they're the ones who set him free
they're the ones that killed the midgard
serpent and sent it there right they're
the ones that did all of that and so
quite literally the hammer says we let
the devil out and the response of thor
is no right you have not met any devil's
mjolnir but you will now this is a huge
moment here right this is something that
i want to specify what's what's
happening here is a huge moment because
what ends up going on is that for a
moment thor is able to encase the power
of the hammer and when that does he
meets with his father now here's the
thing donnie kate's handling of odin in
this story is phenomenal and the reason
why is because like we talked about in
the last video odin's pretty
he's never really been expanded on too
much in terms of like his personality
his mannerisms different things like
that there's been a boatload of stories
where like odin's old sins have come
back to haunt him but the relation
between like odin and thor has always
been that odin was hard on his son and
it was one of those things where she's
like you can be better than what you are
and he was just he was just hard on him
like all the time like never cutting him
any slack and so in the end there's this
conversation that takes place which is
absolutely incredible here what happens
is that thor says we have to get you
help i can carry you to wherever it is
you have to go and the responsive voting
is no i'm not going anywhere you need to
listen to me this hammer is right all of
this was all my fault these are all
things that i have made and they have
all come undone and what he does is he
reaches out to his son and he says all
of them except for you you thor you are
the greatest thing i have ever made and
this is i mean this is this like brings
thor to tears because his father's never
said that his father like odin has never
said that to thor like odin has never
really sat his son down and said just so
you know and like a really really
touching and sentimental moment just so
you know you're my greatest creation
right like that moment in like i was at
iron man 2 when like uh when tony stark
gets that message from his father you
know he's like you are and will forever
be my greatest creation thor never got
that in the comics he's never ever ever
ever really had that even when odin like
died fighting certain he never really
got that what he's getting here is in
reality the one thing he always wanted a
father and that's what odin is being for
like he is being a father like telling
him i will always love you and you have
always been my greatest creation and
odin says but i have been selfish he
says when you took the throne i had so
much more i wanted to do i wanted your
mother to see me again i wanted to be
strong and so i held back now that's
also an important distinction here
because the there was a lot of trouble
in paradise when it came to the
relationship between odin and freya that
in the end they were going their
separate ways right they were just going
to their their own directions and it was
one of those things where it kind of
made sense right the relationship
between odin and freya was something
that had just never truly been explored
in a deep degree in marvel comics it was
just kind of like they're together you
know king and queen of asgard and they
do some stuff and we are here now so
let's continue on with the story and
that's basically all it was and you
never really saw a lot of development
there one of the great things about
what's happened with odin about the
writing of odin over time and really
really starting with jason aaron's run
to a degree is that a lot of the stories
that focus so much on the human side of
ode for example when freya was stabbed
by loki during the war of realms and it
looked like freya was gonna die odin
stayed shut up in his throne room with
freya while he stayed there with her he
would never leave he would never leave
he would never go anywhere he wouldn't
take any visitors he wouldn't hear
anybody all he wanted was to be by his
wife's side and that's completely
understandable right because one of the
best things about this is that you know
for the hard shell that odin puts out in
the end once you look at like a lot of
the modern stories that are going on
with this character he's a lot gentler
than you would think he is now some
people will take that and say see that's
that's ridiculous odin's supposed to be
a hard ass is he really though like is
it is it is it really because i would
say what you're seeing now in donnie
cates is run as a guy who's been reading
comics for 30 years almost this is some
of the best writing on odin that i think
i've ever seen in the history of marvel
comics it's amazing or at least in my
time reading marvel comics it's
absolutely phenomenal but what he says
here is he says with everything that he
was wanting to do that with him holding
back when thor asks what are you saying
i don't understand the response of odin
is he says the odin force it cannot be
given in full until i am gone and odin
sacrifices his life and pours the
entirety of the odin force into thor now
this is an important thing to understand
here because there's only ever been one
time before when thor had the totality
of the odin force you guys know what i'm
talking about ladies and gentlemen you
know what i'm talking about y'all know
what i'm talking about if you've been
reading comics for any measure of time
you know exactly what i'm talking about
there's only been one time when when
thor's had the full totality of the odin
force right thor begs his father no do
not do this odin kills himself
annihilates his own existence and in
doing so takes the entirety of the odin
force and pours it all directly into
thor and so what's crazy is freya
actually senses what's happening she's
just like wait a minute what like is
odin dead and then you get this voice
out of nowhere and literally it's just
mjolnir right like thor just screams and
he's like you have killed in my name
brought misery to my home you have taken
my father and the hammer is just like
what in the hell and thor's like you
wanted to fight you got it come on big
boy let's dance with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace